comme actionnaire un peu je sais comment
ça marche décidé mardi de voir comment
je vais perdre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
disons franchement et que je photo mc
nord était fasciste
shérazade son film est tout à fait
intéressé un passionnant et
stillwater je n'ai pas vu nos maladies
du pied
j'y crois que mes moyens nos précieuses
tous les candidats de gauche oui j'ai
donc tous les moyens sont bons s'il
pouvait y avoir un candidat unique jeu
pourtant le sillage notre dame de la
garde
[Musique]
non c'est mon avis ça fait du travail ça
fait au curé la ville je sais très bien
qu'il vient qu'il vienne à toulouse
nombreux
les jeunes espèrent enfin je crois que
ni à dormir que communiste
non mais en fait parce que tout
simplement parce que je travaille
souvent avec les vingt deux acteurs
comme vous le savez peut-être donc je
vais rester avec leurs quelques années
[Musique]
hyperactif c'est vrai un gâchis social
ça me va pas parce que je suis engagé
tout court et pas que du point de vue
social s'est engagé dans tous les
secteurs de la vie je suis je suis
communiste et puis le troisième mot
serait cinéaste car maman
justice
[Musique]